-Congratulations. You got
married last September.
-I did. September 3rd.
-Congratulations.
-September 3rd.
-Yeah.
-And you -- Your wedding
was covered by
Martha Stewart's magazine.
-It was.
It was covered by Martha.
-Here's a beautiful photo
from the wedding.
-That's my husband, Bill.
-But did you know --
Bill is your husband?
But you guys, did you know were
you going to be on the cover?
Did you know you were
the cover wedding?
-No. We had no idea.
It was, like, such a shock.
We knew that the wedding would
be covered by Martha Weddings.
But we had no idea
that it would be --
-Is it extra stress
when Martha Stewart
is shooting your wedding?
-Yeah, for sure.
I mean, we were, we were very
stressed about the details.
But the biggest thing
was alcohol.
Like, my dad was like,
"There's not enough alcohol,"
the day of the wedding.
-Oh, really?
-He went out that morning,
drove to New Hampshire,
and bought like...
a lot of alcohol.
Because you can take it back.
-Yeah.
-And there's no tax.
-Well, it's tax-free.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm from New Hampshire,
and I'm so proud that that's
what people travel to
our fine state for, yes.
-Yeah, that's, I mean,
the biggest draw.
-Yeah, exactly.
-So, yeah,
we had more than enough.
I think we got like
$6,000 back or something.
-That's great.
-That was, like,
a lot of the wedding budget.
-I like that that was --
Now, your father
is comedian Chris Elliott.
How was he? Was he a good
father of the bride?
Was he -- But he was nervous?
-He was very nervous.
But he pulled it together.
He, like, had a really --
He had the perfect speech.
It was both sweet and funny
and his true form,
and it was just --
it was really nice.
And we danced to Paul Simon.
-What's that?
-We danced to Paul Simon.
-Oh, you danced to Paul Simon.
That's a good one to dance to.
-Yeah, no,
Paul Simon wasn't there.
-His speech was better
than Paul Simon's.
-I didn't dance with Paul Simon.
-"He gave a great speech while
I danced with Paul Simon."
-Yeah.
-And then who --
Did you have the reception
at your house?
-It was in our backyard.
It was a very --
You know, it was pretty formal
for a backyard wedding.
We had a tent and a band
and stuff.
And my dad was very sweet.
He gave our neighbors
bottles of booze before
just because of the noise.
-Gotcha. That's very smart.
-Yeah, I think he, like, slipped
them, like, $100 bills, too.
-Wow. Your dad ran this wedding
like the way you run,
like, an underground
drinking establishment.
And then you, like, grease
the palms of the bootleggers.
-Yeah, yeah.
It was Prohibition Era.
-Yeah, exactly.
But, yeah, we --
And he invited everyone.
He invited all of our neighbors
to the wedding.
-Did he run that by you first?
-No, no. God, no. I would
have been like, "What?"
-Yeah. Were you like, "What?"
when you all of a sudden
saw your neighbors,
like, wandering around?
-Well, we did not expect
any neighbor to come.
There was one guy
in a Hawaiian shirt
roaming around our backyard
with, like,
leather, brown sand--
Like flip-flops.
-Gotcha. Yeah, 'cause that
seems like a courtesy invite
more than a real invite.
-Right, right.
Like, you take the hint
with the $100.
Pocket the $100.
-Don't show up.
And it's like,
"Man, $100, a bottle of booze,
and I get to go get
hors d'oeuvres?!"
-No, he hopped the stone wall
with his --
He had a Bud Light,
but it was, like,
the bottles with,
like, the screw top.
-Oh, right.
-So it wasn't a bottle or a can.
It was, like, one of those,
like, keep-it-cold Bud Lights,
but he also had a koozie on it.
-So that was like
his formal Bud Light.
He dressed it up in its koozie.
-Yeah, exactly.
-That's formal wear for a beer.